hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going to be going over what
i consider to be the three best moments
in all of tokyo avengers so far these
are my most hyped hair-raising or just
favorite emotional moments that i
constantly look back on as pinnacle
points from throughout the entire tokyo
avengers story also there are going to
be some massive spoilers here for you
beautiful anime onlys as we are going to
be covering moments from throughout the
manga so do watch out as you know i
guess i've given you your warning but
just before we do get into the video if
you do enjoy tokyo avengers and want to
know more about the series in general
and keep up to date with the latest
tokyo avengers content then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and also
be sure to leave a like on the video as
it really helps out with the algorithm
and pushes my videos to a bunch of new
amazing people i've also got a discord
server where you can find the latest
releases for manga and content that i
cover so be sure to join there if you're
interested as well but anyway enough of
that let's get into the video so the
first moment i want to go over happens
on chapter 204 and involves an adult
takamichi along with an extremely evil
mikey who had been completely enveloped
into his dark impulses this is
personally my favorite moment of the
entire story so far as it results in the
continuation of the manga with a brand
new arc called the three deities arc
after arriving at a bowling alley that
takamichi thought belonged to the
organization bontine he sat down and
started thinking over his decision of
trying to find mikey even though he was
told it was a suicide mission all of a
sudden he feels a gun pressing to the
back of his head hearing footsteps
approach takamichi listens as a
disheveled mikey tells him that this was
the best future mikey then tells sansu
who was holding the gun to sakamichi's
head to leave and takamichi begins to
ask mikey about what his dark
impulsivities are he then goes on to
explain that he can no longer time leap
as him and naoto have fulfilled their
promise to save hina but because
takamichi believed that this timeline
wasn't one that mikey wanted and he was
again manipulated into this dark path he
stands up and tells mikey that because
he protected everyone it is now his turn
to save him but as he turns around mikey
shoots takamichi who instantly collapses
to the floor
mikey tells takamichi that this is why
he didn't want to meet because he knew
it would end up this way as he walks off
to end everything he tells takamichi
that his long journey ends here
but takamichi on his knees refuses while
wheezing and coughing up blood he tells
mikey that he will save him no matter
what
in retaliation mikey states that he will
end everything here after arriving on
the roof mikey looks out and imagines
the sea of people below him as members
of tournament who are cheering him on
along with his past family members and
friends who have been taken from him in
the past after screaming out he jumps
off the roof and while falling mikey's
hand is caught by takamichi who's
managed to crawl to the window while
losing consciousness takamichi tries his
best to convince mikey to live and crawl
up but he constantly refuses telling
takamichi he wants to end everything
here and now
mikey asks takamichi to let go and put
him at peace but takamichi screams
telling him to shut up and just ask for
help once because if he asks takamichi
will definitely come save him just then
the look and mikey's eyes change and he
begins to tear up and as mikey's hand
starts to slip he grasps takamichi's
hand and asks him to save him all of a
sudden in that moment as their hands
lock takamichi is seen again into the
past but this time instead of being 14
years old he is now 16.
on the emotional side of things this
moment here is absolutely amazing every
single time i record and speak about it
or even while reading panels from this
moment it constantly sends shivers down
my spine and chills reverberate
throughout my entire body just because i
think this moment is absolutely amazing
another reason this moment here is a
pinnacle one throughout the story is how
as i've said it gives us the
continuation of a new arc but this time
it's added an entirely new aspect that
we haven't seen before and this is the
whole future site side of things because
of the inability to travel back to the
future due to the antagonist now being
mikey takamichi is now having to figure
out things as they happen but with the
addition of small visions that show him
the bad outcomes close to the time that
they are about to happen the second
moment that we're going to look at here
is during the start of the tenjiku arc
and takes place just after takamichi and
naoto meet with an adult taiju who gives
them some intel on the current state of
the tokyo manji gang which has evolved
into the organization known as tenjiku
after escaping from the meeting with
taiju which was ambushed by tenjiku
members koko and inyupay takamichi says
to nayosu that he thinks they should
both head back and confront them to try
and get more information that will help
their case but as takamichi turns around
and begins running back to the
restaurant a shadowy figure holding a
gun appears this figure wearing an
all-black trench coat turned out to be
teta kasaki as he tells takamichi to die
naoto rushes over and knocks takamichi
out of the way sustaining a fatal bullet
wound to the back of his body
screaming out his name takamichi crawls
over and cradles the head of a
critically wounded naoto while naoto
tells takamichi to run with her
footsteps and a mysterious person state
to kasaki that he was supposed to be the
one to kill naoto and which kisaki
remarks to izana that he couldn't do
much as naoto tried to protect takamichi
and got in the way walking up izana
tells naoto and takamichi that they
killed his mikey he then cheerfully
calls out kokucho to finish off the pier
walking up an obedient kokucho pulls out
his revolver and without saying a word
blasts takamichi in the chest and
stomach leaving him bleeding out right
next to a naoto whose life is now slowly
fading away as they lie on the ground
together naoto remarks that he
constantly thought to himself that how
can takamichi this pathetic wimp really
pull this all off how could his sister
fall in love with such a person he
remarks that he finds it weird but when
he thinks back no matter how many times
he failed he would always find his way
back to naoto
naoto says that that's how a hero would
act like takamichi he never gives up
even if they constantly fail he then
tells takamichi that he is his pride and
reaches out saying that this here is
their final handshake remarking that
death sure is scary naoto and takamichi
slide their blood-soaked hands across
the concrete and grasp their hands
together one last time as takamichi
remembers the people that he needs to
take down he states to himself that this
will not be the last handshake as he
will never give up
i absolutely love this moment every
single time i reread this chapter it
brings out a flurry of emotion and i'll
usually begin to tear up i feel like
this is because the first time in over
130 chapters it finally feels like
someone has noticed the immeasurable
amount of work that takamichi has put in
to try and save the ones that he loves
as readers we've seen him grow from this
26 year old immature male with a narrow
mindset who will constantly let people
walk all over him to now continuously
standing up for what he believes in even
at the sacrifice of his own life he
won't back down or give up and it's even
more evident when again we see him
internalize his determination stating
that this will not be the last handshake
this moment here also for the first time
lets us know the full scale of what
happens when takamichi really messes up
as if naoto is dead in the future he
will be unable to travel back to his
original timeline leaving him stranded
until he is able to fix things or dies
himself in the past
the third and final moment that i
consider to be one of the best moments
from throughout the entire tokyo
avengers story so far happens on chapter
184 and involves the main antagonist and
the main protagonist of the tokyo
avengers story that being takamichi
hanagaki and tetakisaki during the final
scuffle between kisaki and takamichi
takamichi manages to disarm kisaki's gun
and while pointing the gun akisaki
himself states that if he kills kisaki
here he can save hina
just as takamichi is about to pull the
trigger and kill kisaki himself hina and
mikey show up calling out his name in
this moment takamichi turns his head to
see his friends approaching but while he
does this kisaki takes the time to try
and escape by running off but takamichi
quickly chases after him telling hisaki
that it is over because no one trusts
him anymore his ruse of using people is
up and his pathetic dreams have failed
bakisaki remarks that he won't let it
end here and that one day hina will be
his for sure takamichi replies screaming
out saying that he won't let that happen
and won't let hisaki escape back to the
future timeline again hearing this
kisaki comes to a complete standstill in
the middle of a crossing and asks
takamechi if he thinks he is a time
leaper as takamichi walks closer to
kisaki confused he asks if he is or not
at the exact same time in the distance a
rogue truckkin takes control of the
vehicle overriding the driver and
sticking it in sixth gear sending the
truck flying down the suburban streets
of japan all jokes aside just before
kisaki replied to takamichi giving him
an answer a speeding truck slams into an
unaware kasaki who was seen flying over
the other side of the road
wounded beyond repair a broken kisaki
does his best to try and get back up to
his feet but his mangled body won't
listen to him and stops him from being
able to get back up
as his body begins to slump back down to
the ground kisaki says that he does not
want to die before passing away in the
middle of the street alone
so obviously i had to include this in my
top three because well it's all three of
the things that i see the abs moment was
about this moment has so much hype
behind it like you can go to any kisaki
video and find someone in the comments
representing the man himself drakkon but
like that joke aside kisaki was the main
antagonist of the entire story and has
been with us for like almost 200
chapters now he brought forth a majority
of most of the hair-raising or
nail-biting moments through his callous
or the genius plans that he formulates
he in turn is kind of what makes
takamichi so great and why he shines so
bright in everyone else's eyes and i
think this moment here brings the genius
madman to an end through something he
could never have expected and something
that takamichi certainly had no
foresight towards
i also think this moment is an extremely
emotional one not necessarily for
everyone but i think how he died was
quite brutal and i'm not gonna say he
didn't exactly deserve it but seeing
someone say they didn't want to die
before they slumped in the middle of a
road was quite a sad moment or at least
it was in my eyes let me know what you
guys all think down in the comment
section below about his death and
whether or not you agree or disagree
with what i consider to be the top three
moments in all of tokyo avengers
so far at least also if you want me to
make a part two also be sure to comment
down below as honestly there are like a
bunch of moments to choose from and it
was extremely hard to even pick three
like just just for this video alone
we've got the baji's death or ms death
well the moment you know mikey shows up
during the tenjiku up or even the moment
that mikey shows up during the the black
dragons arc i absolutely love that
moment well the moment they're taking me
she tells sakai that you know loneliness
is the saddest thing and there's so many
amazing moments throughout this entire
series so be sure to check the comment
down below with you know
what you'd like me to go over and i'll
be sure to make another video if this
one does well if you guys are new around
here and want to keep up to date with
the latest tokyo avengers content and i
guess just more anime content in general
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as it really really helps
out with the algorithm and pushes my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
also be sure to check out the membership
option for my channel if you want to
support me even further but anyway for
now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit bye
[Music]
you